here's a light-hearted version of a
partial bibliography or reading list for
true hallucinations in alphabetical
order more ms Burroughs William and
Ginsburg Allen the yah-hey letters
citylights books 1960 take a stab DeJong
the hieroglyphic monad translated by JW
Hamilton Jones London 1947 DeLillo dawn
Ratner star W Evans Vance w/e the fairy
faith in Celtic countries and of course
the famous article by s Gasol SK due to
a case on y'all and a Quebrada chharia
arundo donax grameena e phytochemical
and pharmacological evaluation in the
Journal of medical chemistry vol 12 1969
page 480 graves Robert the white goddess
New York 1948 hartenberg w e the
Putumayo The Devil's paradise London
1912 partner Michael the sound of
rushing water natural history July 1968
Huxley Aldous the doors of perception
Joyce James Finnegan's Wake
London 1939 Ulysses ditto slightly
earlier Yong Eric the self-organizing
universe young Carl Gustav flying
saucers a modern myth of things seen in
the sky lightness Wolfgang von Mona
dalla G Lewis Wyndham the human age
blood
pricks hue the Hashi Shiva Meyer Michael
atalanta fugiens Nabokov Vladimir Pale
Fire in New York 1963 also tea and
honorary go in psilocybin the magic
mushroom growers guide Berkeley 1975
phenom Kurama and Cameron scientific
perspectives on extraterrestrial
communication Boston 1974 the works of
ilya prigogine Pynchon thomas gravity's
rainbow new york 1974 Rilke Rainier
Maria the Duino elegies Shorty's Richard
Evans Verona is an orally administered
hallucinogen botanical museum leaflets
of Harvard University vol 22 number 6
Stapleton Olaf the Star Maker Valentine
fossil the triumphal chariot of Antony
ballet Jacques the invisible College and
messengers of deception the complete
works of Gordon Wasson Wells Herbert
George the time machine white-haired
Alfred North process and reality wilson
robert anton Illuminatus and i might an
valus by philip k dick